Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast and ah ha ha ha.
I'm checking in on you.
Youuu.
Oh, sorry. Uh, how are Ya? Um, and
Health Helsinki. I'm in Helsinki. I got a,
I just did Stockholm the other night.
I did Copenhagen two shows the night
before and fucking Iceland on Monday.
Been having a great
time. Joe Barton. Nick.
Yeah.
Comment over here. Like he's always
been over here. I actually asked him,
cause he's been crushing so hard
and so not like in his head,
you know, about being over here thinking
of, I'm going to do a joke about ducks.
Do they have ducks?
Do I need to say Canard?
He hasn't been doing any of that
shit. And, um, he's been killing.
So I asked him last night when
we were in Stockholm. I was like,
how many times you've been over here?
And he goes, Europe, that's fight.
Yeah. And he goes, never.
That's why people love Joe Barton,
Nick,
because Joey B is Joey be
no matter where he is. Um,
yeah, he's been killing and I've been, uh,
I've been having some good sets
over here trying out the new shit,
the race against him.
Time, you know, I heard Joe Rogan
say the other day that he was,
he put in six months of work and he's
got a new hour that he's happy with,
you know,
cause this special came out and um,
yeah,
you know, I was, I don't know, I just get,
I get like amped up when I hear
shit like that, but uh, so I'm,
I'm trying not to jump the gun.
If you guys are you,
if you want to hear my process,
my process about building a new hour is
I usually dump this shit on most sick of
first. You know what I mean?
And a, it's a weird time.
It's a weird time for your act because
what happens is you get really excited
about the new stuff
stuff and then the old stuff still
works and nobody's really seen it yet,
but you, you, you know,
you're getting rid of it.
So you feel like you ever
go on a date with somebody,
you know.
And you know,
you're going to break up with
them and you're out to dinner and,
and she's just like, you want dessert?
You're like, no, no, let's wrap this up.
Um, that's how, that's, that's what
you have to fight with your jokes.
Like you start trying to wrap them up
and then jokes that were funny or now not
funny because you're trying
to rush through them. So, um,
I kind of figured that out the
last couple of nights and, uh,
had some great shows and, um, I dunno,
I did stock home last night and some
of this stuff people said to me on the
stage was making me a little
nervous where I was like,
uh, you know, I said something, I'm
not a big political guy, but, uh,
I've been doing this joke over
here where I just go, um, you know,
and as you all know in America right now,
we currently have our greatest
president of all time. You know,
and people usually laugh because
generally speaking they don't like him.
And it was sort of quiet. It's, there was
a couple people who just went like, yeah,
Woo.
It's just like really and hung out with
some people afterwards and they will
kind of say in that, uh Oh and I
mentioned, I mentioned during the show,
I was saying this is nothing
against people from Stockholm
that just let me know
where people are kind of ad.
And then it was saying
I go, can I ask you a question?
I go, is this bullshit?
Gonna start up again over here.
And they kind of got a little
uncomfortable like and kind of said, yeah,
I don't know if they were joking or what
the bullshit meaning another world war.
MMM.
I Dunno.
It's weird.
And then I kind of talked to some people
afterwards and granted Allie talked to
two people and it was their opinion,
but they was saying that it's just kind
of getting like racist or whatever.
Not like it ever went away. I
Dunno. People are fucking awful.
But those two people I talked to
a nice and you know, something,
90% of the fucking people
that I talked to, one nice
and you know, the rest are like racist
or like hardcore feminists, you know,
just people you can't even have
a fucking conversation with.
MMM.
Sounding really ignorant to walk through
the fucking world thinking that you
have all the answers and you're
going to be the one that solves it.
How long have people been on this
planet? I Dunno. When did Jesus die?
Fucking 2020 years ago. Then you
had what, like 500 years before him?
Is that what it was? I, you know,
I have no idea how long people have
been on this planet. Hang on a second.
Let me look that up.
How long have people,
it'd be funny just to leave it there
to see what they suggest that I said,
search here. How long
have people, no suggestion
then I can't say here. Right. That's
even, that's even too stupid for Google.
How long have people been on,
on the earth?
This'll take me to Scientology. Well,
before we were in a spaceship. Um,
how long have people been on earth?
Do you imagine if Scientology is right?
There was some spaceship,
right?
And then they just fucking dropped us
down here with absolutely no fucking what
I mean, how far, how far in advance
would they be technologically?
Right.
Anybody?
Can you hear me here?
And then they just fucking leave
you to start all over again.
And then that would basically be the,
this would be a global like survivor,
like this big fucking reality
show that they're watching.
MMM.
Here's a question and he's signed
to ologists listen to this.
Here's my question that goes,
how this reminds me of this Joe
Rogan bit he used to do about Noah's,
where he was talking about how many
species of plant or on the planet,
and if he had two of each, and he was
like, how big is this fucking boat?
Doesn't that kind of
work with Scientology?
Like do you guys have a finite number
of members that you can have and at that
point,
like the spaceships not going to be
big enough or is it going to be a whole
fleet?
I Dunno.
I Dunno why that religion has been
interesting meeting. Interesting me.
Interesting. I think right there. I
just got Gab. We don't need this guy.
All right. How have, how long
have humans been on earth?
Why can't they just answer the question?
This is what I fucking hate about smart
people. They got to go on and on and on.
It starts up while our ancestors have
been around for about 6 million years,
just give me a number.
What am I buying a fucking car here?
Yeah.
While our ancestors had been
around for about 6 million years,
the modern form of humans only
evolved about 200,000 years ago.
Yeah. Weren't they like two
different kinds? And one of them, uh,
live than the other ones. Didn't.
There's somebody beat somebody else.
I don't know. The only part I don't think
I know about that history is a movies,
not even documentaries.
That's how not read. I am.
I don't even watch documentaries.
A civilization as we know it.
It's only about 6,000 years old. So
what does that mean? Running water?
That goes back to Roman times.
They held the title for 4,000
years before they whacked Jesus.
Was that their downfall?
They killed Jesus.
Is that what happened or do they
stretch it out too far like Hitler?
Did they fight a war on two fronts?
I mean,
I'll just fucking melts together
after a while, doesn't it?
All right about 6,000 years old and
industrialization started in the,
in earnest only in the
18 hundreds. Ah, Jesus.
Yeah.
Future generations are paying for that.
But I'll tell you what a
fucking life we're living
flat screen TVs and fucking cell phones.
Speaking of cell phones.
Helsinki.
I'm in Helsinki.
This is where no Kia started angry birds.
What else are they known for here?
Hockey.
Yeah.
Valtteri Botox. Huh? Who fucking
one? I got, I got to see that race.
It's just going to be like the
first year I watched when, uh, uh,
Lewis Hamilton went up against the
other guy there that Lily Ricky Schroder
looking dude,
Nico Rosberg
and he fucking won beat Louis Hamilton.
And then his girlfriend was like,
I don't want you to do it anymore.
And he was like, all right.
Oh.
Um, I don't think that's what happened
because he's still stayed away.
At some point he would have dumped her.
He would have missed the sound
of the engine. Right. All right.
So I guess we've been around for 6,000
years as we know it 200,000 years ago.
The first fucking humans.
Yeah.
I'll tell you what's fucking amazing
about all of this is I have no idea why he
fucking looked this up. I Dunno. Can you,
can it really be this,
this is my new thing,
how I deal with my short term memory when
I can't remember stuff. I just think,
well, you know, if I can't remember
it, was it really that important? Um,
anyway, plowing ahead here.
Uh, here's a great story.
It's not a great story. It
kind of itself. All right.
Oh Wow. Why did they do that? Shit. We're
going to make you watch this fucking ad.
I don't want to watch
it close the fucking ad.
I'm going to hit mute because they don't
get paid. Is that what the fuck it is?
Stop. Stop. Thank you. All right. Uh,
venture fans brutally beat man outside
cinema after he loudly revealed the
surprise ending to the
blockbuster end game movie.
I love both sides of this story.
I mean,
that is just the ultimate conti
thing to do with. So fucking funny.
And then I got to admit,
you have to respect how much people
care about this franchise and if you're
going to do something like that,
I mean,
he kinda got the ass kick
and he deserved, right? Uh,
thank God it was a mob and
nerds who repeat fucking dead.
Do you realize what you have to do?
I mean,
nerds is supposed to be these nonviolent
people who just kind of sit around and
be awkward all the time.
I love that they fucking tapped
into their inner chuck Norris.
You found the breaking point.
You go in and you fuck with their
superhero franchise. Look at them.
They turn into their cavemen selves
from 200,000 years ago. Look at me.
Sounded smart all of a sudden. Um, I mean,
they surpassed modern civilization as
we've known it for the last 6,000 years
and went back to our earliest ancestors
at 2000 years. Listen to that, huh?
The beginning of a Dennis Miller joke.
I think I'm smart now. I'm a man,
has reportedly been beaten outside,
beaten up outside his cinema after
loudly revealing the plot of the new
adventure film to queuing fans. Q, u,
e you ing. There you go. There goes all
my dentist melanoma dummy again, uh,
film queuing to queuing
fans who hadn't seen it yet.
So he walked out of a showing and they
were all standing in line and he went,
the hulk is green because he has
gunnery, ours, whatever the fucking,
whatever the fuck he yelled up because
they're all banging wonder woman.
Is this even the right franchise?
Um,
someone was trying to tell me that
they've made 23 of these movies,
23 of these fucking movies,
just,
just for all you other people who
just watch sports, like make, um,
just to give you a motive for how this
guy turned a pack of fucking awkward
nerds.
So you could probably walk up,
slap him in the head and take their
fucking popcorn and they wouldn't do
anything as long as they
held onto their movie ticket.
This guy found out what it was.
Yeah.
It reminded me of a long time ago,
this guy ran for president that I
voted for and I can't even remember his
fucking name.
MMM.
He was the guy that everybody blamed for
the first George Bush for getting in.
You know,
cause everybody made the assumption that
if you voted for this guy than there,
than if you didn't vote for that guy,
you would have voted for fucking Al Gore.
MMM.
Forgetting the fact of how fucking
horrific Al Gore was all fucking sweaty.
Al, you didn't laugh enough in
the last debate. You didn't smile.
Then also was just like Ho, Ho, Ho,
Ho, Ho looking like a fucking robot.
Um, let me see. Well, looking
back, that was a fucking era.
We should, you know, I didn't give
a fuck if you're conservative.
I think we should've Gone Al Gore,
you know,
then maybe we don't go to Iraq and become
bankrupt and have to give champions of
sports fast food when they
show up at the White House.
I'll probably oversimplifying all of this,
but you know,
I'm a man who just learned how long
you've been on this planet. So why,
why are you listening to me?
MMM [inaudible]
all right. What the fuck am
I talking about here? Yeah.
So this guy found the fuck it's anybody's,
he's been made 23 of these fucking movies.
So let's just say the
average movie is 90 minutes.
Two hours long.
Okay.
These poor people standing
in line had 46 hours
invested into this wall.
Wait,
yeah,
we'll say 44 hours plus the trap l
all the fucking money that they spent.
And this was the final one.
And that fucking asshole. I've,
I've, I wonder if he was even a fan
if he just went in like this was
like some sort of like, I mean,
that's like something opie and Anthony
would have come up with back in the day,
like some brilliant
fucking thing like that.
MMM.
I don't know.
This is one of these weird ones
where I kind of see both sides of it.
Like what that kid did was fucking
hilarious and it was also horrific.
Any deserved the ass kick.
And I'm on both sides of the fence here.
MMM.
I would love to interview
this kid and ask.
Just ask him, why did you do that?
Did you know you are going to do it?
Do you have Tourette's or something?
Like why the fuck did you do
that and what were you thinking
when they started to attack you?
Do you regret doing it?
MMM,
I dunno. I mean, if I'm sitting on that
jury, I say that those fans had motive.
I'm arguing. I mean, these
days, I mean, that's like,
you got to think how young the
average fucking fan is of this.
I mean, they invested half
their fucking lives into this.
This guy just came in and told them what,
I don't know what chimney Santa
Claus was coming down. I haven't,
you know what I have no,
I don't know.
There's so many of these fucking things
that people are telling you. You gotta.
Why have you seen game of Thrones?
Have you seen fucking ah,
what is this one called the Avengers
and you just get so like
fucking hopelessly behind.
It reminds me of my junior year in math
class. No, my senior year, junior year,
I still tried. I tried until
October and it just gets to this,
there's like a point where you're just
so far behind that you just give up hope.
Like I'm not passing, I can't, I
what the eye, I'm just too far behind
like a, I don't think I'll
ever see game of Thrones,
which is a sad thing because I know
it's really good. I t you know,
what is it like 19 fucking seasons
is something you've got to fucking,
uh, I remember lost lost was the
first one that I was just like,
I was too far behind and I
was just like, I, I'm not,
I'm not fucking watching this.
And then they fucked everybody
on the ending of that.
So that one I feel good about.
Maybe that's the way you do it.
Yeah.
What'd you do is you let other people
go on point and you let them watch the
show for you and then they'll
report back to you like, oh my God,
that fucking ending sucked. What a waste
of fucking time. Then you go, all right,
we'll fuck that then. Right?
All right, so avenger fence.
Is it worth me?
MMM,
yeah.
Sitting down
for 46 hours.
That should literally be like a
fucking, you know, if anybody,
you can stay awake for 46 straight hours
and watch all avenger movies right in a
row.
The last person to fall asleep,
the last person to fall asleep.
I don't know.
When's the two big green hulk fists,
whatever the fuck you people are into. Ah,
Shit.
Somebody just sent me a text.
I was trying to think of the name of this
fucking comedian who I just doesn't do
it anymore. It probably is into producing
or something like that. Whatever.
What do either way,
I hope they happy.
Just you have answers to somebody fucking
head. Their face pops into your head.
You know when you're like,
what the fuck was that guy's name?
I haven't seen him forever,
you know?
Yeah.
So then you can look them up on Facebook
and see what the fuck they're at
and you see how much older they are and
then you realize that you look that much
older than them and you don't recognize
any of the people that they're with.
And it's like, did I ever even
fucking know that person? You know?
Then you just start thinking like,
what is it all about?
What the fuck am I doing out here?
Is this what my life is going
to beautiful cities for 17 hours
and getting on another plane and leaving.
Then you look to see if they got a late
night menu and you start ordering bad
food and you know, just
start spiraling down. Um, no,
I've been doing, uh, I, I
didn't do well in Iceland.
I was on vacation when I was
in Iceland and then I, uh, oh,
Billy was getting the, was getting
the old belly coming back. But um,
I dunno, I had a couple of fucking
moments there. I've always like,
I don't like going fishing. I
like it, but then I don't like it.
It's exciting and all of that.
But like, I just don't like,
it's weird because I've eaten
so much fish in my life,
but to actually fucking pull it out
of the sea, see how beautiful it is,
and then fucking kill the thing,
you know?
Yeah,
man, I felt bad. I didn't even eat the
fucking head too. It's like Jesus Christ,
Dude. What the fuck?
You know? I don't know.
We through the rest of it into the
fucking ocean, but it bugged me. The cows,
I never been. I know cows were that good
looking. So this is what I'm doing now.
Because you know what's funny is I
know all you guys are cringing going,
oh my God.
Is he going to start wearing Birkenstocks
and become an bill Bergen stocks?
Right?
Hey,
he's going to get a fucking,
I'm going to scotch tape a man bun to
the back of my bald head and then I'm
going to start preaching to you
guys about fucking being a Vegan.
Oh Dude, this is such a
fucked up analogy, man. Um,
cause I gotta tell you something like,
you know how cruel they are to fucking
animals as a carnivore and you just don't
want to watch it.
If you have any sort of heart,
you just don't want to watch it
and you just fucking block it out.
I saw this thing where they are this,
there's some conservative talk show
hosts that got a fucking death threat.
So I'm like, who the hell is this
guy? I don't know who this guy is.
So I looked him up and he
did this fucking thing,
some rant on like abortion
and you know,
he showed, I I saw like 0.5 seconds
he showed a picture of an abortion.
I was just like, dude, what the fuck?
MMM.
You know, I'm not going to get involved
in my views on that thing. I, you know,
whatever you want to do is
whatever you want to do. But uh,
you might want to look at some photos.
Jesus fucking Christ.
It's one of the worst
things I've ever seen. Um,
I probably shouldn't have said that
because now his fans are going to say,
I'm not going to get
involved in that shit.
And I don't want to fucking
sit there cause I don't, I
don't know shit. All right,
so don't fuck, I'm not an ally of
either side of that fucking argument.
I think it's your own fucking do whatever
the fuck you want to do. Okay. But yeah,
you should probably look at a slide
show first. It's all I can say.
Um, so I haven't said that. This
is what I'm going to do now. Um,
I think when I'm on the road,
I'm going to be vegetarian for the fee.
Like for breakfast I had eggs. Oh,
that's still vegetarian, right? No,
that's a meet. I already
fucked it up. Whatever.
I was going to be tried to
go veggie for the first, uh,
for breakfast and then for lunch and
then for dinner I'll have a laugh,
something, you know, and
uh, I'll see how that goes.
I've been doing that for the last
couple of days and it's good. I started,
I'm dropping, fucking wait. You
know, I'm not gonna lie to you.
I'm shitting like a fucking race horse.
It's ridiculous.
It's like I'm going to a bathroom,
like a fucking cocaine.
People looking at me waiting
to snip. It's like, ah,
you're looking at the wrong end. Damn.
Um, alright. Abortions, shit jokes.
Dead Animals. Where else did we
go from here? World War three?
I think we pretty much, I think it's
time for some advertising. All right,
let's do it here. Um, what
do we got here? We got up.
This is a long, long, hey look.
You know right in about that,
right in about fucking remember in faces,
but forgetting the names and then you
remember him and then you'd go on Facebook
and try to look them up and just see
where the, where the fuck they ended up.
You know, whenever I do that, I just
said, I pray to God, they happy.
I want to see joy. That's what I
want to see. You know, I'm not,
I'm not as big a Qantas. Everybody
thinks I'm all right. Here we go.
Where am I? Where am I? Where am I? Jesus.
Oh man, they want me to read all of this.
Okay. Oh Jesus. What a how?
Ironically after what I was
just talking about butcher box,
butcher box.
Is that ironic because of abortion talk
or is that ironic because of fucking
veganism? Who knows you? You
make your choice. It's up to you.
Um, all right, butcher box everybody.
I've got to scroll back up here right now.
Put your boxes offering new members
two pounds of free wild caught Alaskan
Salmon. $20 off their first box.
Butcher box sources. They're pure wild,
sustainably harvest salmon
from Bristol Bay, Alaska.
You can tell by the color that this salmon
is always fresh. Never factory farmed.
A new members.
We'll get two pounds of wild
caught Alaskan sockeye salmon.
These must be, this must be
the tough fish, huh? Fuck.
Are you looking at a for free
plus $20 off your first box?
This is an awesome deal.
I'll tell you right now,
I can never be a Vegan because
every time I read this,
my mouth waters a butcher box makes it
easy to get high quality meat that you
can trust every month.
Butcher box delivers 100% grass fed
and grass finished beef free range,
organic chicken heritage breed pork,
my favorite and wild Alaskan salmon
directly to you deal with the incredible
quality of butcher box meets.
Starts with the commitment to humanely
raised animals that are never fed
antibiotics or hormones did. We mentioned
it's delivered right to your door.
Choose from for curated boxes, including
a mix of high quality grass fed grass,
finished beef, grass fed, grass finished
beef. Oh cause you can say grass fed.
And then they feed it another cow.
You gotta make sure he said grass
finished to free range organic chicken and
heritage breed pork or customize your
own box so that you can get exactly what
you want and your family, what
you and your family loves. Sorry.
Now for $20 off, one more time. Uh,
your first order and to free pounds
of wild Alaskan sockeye salmon.
Go to butcher box.com/burr or rent the
promo or enter the Promo Code Burr.
Oh, mother's Day's coming up. Everybody.
And guess who's back on the podcast.
Sherry's berries,
Sherry's berries.
That that they like my fucking, they
like my Meg Ryan in when Harry met Sally,
what together we're broken up.
What banging where you know,
separated Sherry's berries.
Mother's Day is coming up and there's
absolutely nothing most of us wouldn't do
to make sure the special
moms in our lives are happy.
Talk about your moms and why she deserves
to be happy this month because she's
my mom.
I have to go into fucking detail.
How bad was your mother,
Sherry, that I, she's my mother.
Talk about the best,
worst,
funniest reactions you received
after sending a mother's Day.
I always send her something nice.
They give her a great car and she smiles.
She hugs me and tells me she loves
because she's mean. She's the best.
Motivate your audience. I know what I'm
doing. Talk about your God. Jesus Christ.
Sherry's berries has special mother's Day.
Barry's design just,
they're like Michael Douglas in
that fucking movie dumped dads.
It's like you're telling me I know what
to do on the fucking coffee. Cherries.
Berries has special mother days.
Barry designed just for mom that are
top with chocolate chip, pink Schumer,
sugar,
and swizzles.
Describe how much these gourmet goodies
would make the special mom in your life.
Smile. Well, ever day.
I think she would like chocolate
chips the best I would think.
I hope she would wait til she brushed
her teeth afterwards before she smiled.
You know,
it'd be perfectly honest with you.
You choose your delivery date to ensure
mom gets your gift of Sherry's berries
exactly when you want her to, and your
satisfaction is always guaranteed.
Don't wait until the
last minute on this one.
Visit berries.com to order today freshly
dipped strawberries starting in 1999
for the mom in your
life or a mom's plural.
Now,
what's that for?
Is that for people who say my mom's
or is that for people with alternative
lifestyles or is it for everybody?
I don't know.
To make mom really happy, you could
double the berries for just $10 more.
Mother's Day is Sunday,
May 12th so visit berries.com that's B,
e r r I e s.com.
Click on the microphone in the upper
right corner and enter my code burr.
That's berries.com click the microphone
code burr. All right. And lastly,
but not leastly quip.
The new kids quip has the same two
minute timer and guiding pulses as our
original version with no childish
gimmicks so they can brush.
Just like a grownup. Motivate your
audience. Talk. Well, what the fuck is it?
It's a toothbrush.
You know,
I was never an electric toothbrush guy.
You got to do it.
If you have the regular
ones that your gums,
you brush your gums away is what happens.
And then you get a perio
Donald fucking issue, right?
And then you're going to get to
k and then your teeth fall out.
Then you have stomach
problems and then you die.
So I think you should get this
toothbrush. How was that? Quit a kids.
The new brush is the same
as our original version.
Just tweaked for size down mile.
Oh, they got them for kids.
Now I'll have to get my daughter
one of these. Uh, you know,
if you sent me a free one, maybe I could
talk a little more informed about it.
Wink, wink, nudge, nudge.
Their kids are inspired to brush better
and more often with oral care that looks
and feels like the products the
adults in their life views and they,
they're proud to use.
Quip,
help them develop a grownup
routine without childish gimmicks.
Kid friendly features like a
small brush head, watermelon,
anticavity toothpaste and
rubber grip handles and colors.
Little ones will love sensitive sonic
vibrations for an effective clean that
gent that's gentle on your sensitive gums.
Why people brush too hard and
some electric toothbrushes
are too abrasive built
in two minute timer,
pulses every 30 seconds to remind you
when to switch sides and help you to clean
your whole mouth. That's why, uh,
you should love quip and why over 1
million happy, healthy mouse do too.
I'm telling you,
man,
you get this thing and you floss and you
actually pay attention to the beeping
and all that type of stuff.
You're going to save yourself
an incredible amount of
headaches in your life.
You can have a beautiful smile.
You're not going to get your teeth pulled
and I have to get a partial and all of
that fucking crap and you
won't ruin your stomach, uh,
cause you'll actually be able
to chew your food anyways.
Quip starts at just 25
bucks. And if you get to, uh,
if you get quip.com Q u
I p slash bar right now,
you can get your first refill
pack for free. That's right.
Your first refill pack for free at Geet,
Q u I
p.com/burr. All right,
beautiful. And that's it.
And of all freckles, I'm going to, uh,
this is what I'm going forward here
in Helsinki. I'm getting fresh,
a fresh seasonal salad.
Then I'm getting a salmon soup.
So what am I'm fucking trying,
I'm trying in, uh, any uh,
vegetarians or vegans out there that,
you know,
you got some good meals that I
can kind of toss it in there. I,
I'd love to do it cause I'm feeling
pretty good. Feeling light on my,
on my freckled toes here,
my freckled paste Ito's um,
just don't give me any that Tofu shit.
All right.
I don't like Tofu. I don't know what Tofu
is. I don't know what it's trying to be.
And I also don't like that
shit where it's like, uh,
you know where they have like the fake
meat. Like I like a black bean burger,
you know,
or if you make a lentil burgers,
it's actually made from something I
don't like when they just mush a bunch of
shit together and then try to make it
look like meat. It's just like, you know,
it's like be yourself, you
know, be with the fuck you are.
I have a great recipe for a, uh, uh,
a lentil burger where it's also like,
it's got beets in it,
the is Cilantro and some other green shit
that you put in there and a little bit
of bread crumbs.
It's fucking tremendous,
but it's hard to eat that when
you're out here on the road.
That was the one thing I did
like about Iceland though,
is as much as I didn't order anything like
that, they did have plenty of options.
So anyways, um, I'll see how this goes.
You know,
I think I'm always going to eat meat,
but I think I'm going to do it like once
a day as opposed to like fucking three
times a day. And um, part
of its cousin animals.
I'll tell you what's weird about
pigs is UBC a little piglet.
They're fucking adorable. And then
you think, I can't believe I eat that.
But then you just see some fat pig
and it's just like Adam gave a fuck.
Give it to behind. It's
pickier. Let's fuck it. Eat.
Um, anyways. All right, that's it. Uh,
thank you to everybody's been
coming out on this tour, man.
I'm playing these fucking
really impressively sized
venues over here that have
been absolutely beautiful and it blows
my mind that people are coming out here.
So I do want to take the time
to say thank you for that.
And I'm really looking forward.
I got two shows here tonight and uh,
in Helsinki and
then it's on to Oslo,
Norway.
And then I'm in Amsterdam and we got
the next day off and I'm in Amsterdam,
although we are traveling to
Tel Aviv. But, uh, you know,
that's going to be fun. Put it that
way, but I'm not drinking, you know,
I think I'm going to eat like a pot cookie
or something like that and just walk
around the just city, mildly tripping. Uh,
I will not be getting on a bicycle, but
uh, yeah, that's what I'm going to do.
I think that's what the fuck I'm gonna
do you no good. Clean Fun. All right.
That's it. Enjoy your weekend,
your cons. Enjoy the music.
And we've got another half hour of
the biggest hits Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast from a year ago.
[inaudible] I always forget how it does.
All right, let's see. I'm just somebody
[inaudible] [inaudible]
hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
May 2nd, 2011. Um,
how the hell are you?
Um,
this is a landmark week from
me in my career and, uh,
and in this podcast because
for the first time ever,
I'm actually, I have an
advertiser, no bullshit.
I have an advertiser,
like a real live radio show on this
podcast and I know what you guys are
thinking, you're probably like, Oh gee,
he's got advertising. So
what does that mean, Bill?
Does that mean you're not going to
use the word content anymore? No,
it does not. Does that mean you're
going to tone it down? No, it doesn't.
All it means is that it continues
to be fucking free for you.
Cheap motherfuckers. Not Kidding. A cheap,
just a financially challenged
motherfuckers. You still mother fuckers,
you're still fuckers of mothers.
But anyways,
so this week for the
first time ever I do have,
I'm going to have some advertising and
I'm actually working on some tee shirts
and that type of thing. I'm trying
to take this thing to the next level.
Maybe you have a merge page.
Whatever the hell I got to do a,
I appreciate everybody who's gone on to
the [inaudible] podcast page and clicked
on the donation button. Um, I
appreciate it. I really appreciate it.
So with that, um, this week,
my one and only advertised
to the first ever legends,
one of these legendary moments in
the podcast. Like when I, when I,
I switched from a yapping on my phone as
I drove down the street and I actually
got a mixer. Um, this is the first
advertiser and you're probably thinking,
hey bill, what are you going to do?
Are you going to advertise some booze?
You can advertise some
weed. Uh, no I'm not.
I'm actually going to give a lot of guys
out there. A little bit of a heads up.
Mother's Day is coming up this
Sunday, isn't it? I Dunno,
I didn't look it up. I think it is. See,
this is what happens every mother's Day,
right? Who Doesn't love their mother?
Serial killers,
right?
Syrah killers don't love their mothers.
Everybody else, you'll love your mother,
right? But as much as you
try every year, what happens?
Mother's Day sneaks up on you and all
of a sudden Saturday night you're out
drinking a couple of couple of fucking
Pale Ales and all of a sudden somebody
mentions it, you know the waitress with
their fucking cleavage, Chang and out.
She'll mention, oh yeah, tomorrow. You
know, you're trying to pick her up a,
what do you, what are you doing
tomorrow? And we should hang out,
go play fucking horse shoes or some,
you know,
my brother's got a cottage
up in New Hampshire, doe.
She come up there and then
she's like, I can't, I am.
I'm spending time with my mother's
tomorrow because it's mother's Day.
And then what do you do? You Go, Oh fuck,
it's mother's Day. So what do you do?
You run down to cvs, you
know, any port in a storm,
you run down to the local drugstore and
you go and you try to find a fucking
mother's Day card. But by the time you
get down there, there's only two left,
right? What do you got?
There's the fucking one that
has like a fart joke on it.
And then the one that's so affectionate,
it's borderline incestuous, right?
So now what are you can
now you get a shitty car.
The fucking envelopes are all creased up,
delaying laying all over the fucking
place and your mother can see it.
When you hand it to her, she could
see it. It's not a good card.
It's just like you,
motherfucker.
I carried you around in my fucking
home for nine months. I raised your,
Brad asked the entire fucking life, and
this is what you do. You get me the, the,
the, the goddamn leftover card
that nobody wanted at cvs.
You couldn't even go to Walmart and
get me a shack at to go along with it.
All right, well, I have the solution.
This is a classic thing for guys. Uh, my,
my sponsor this week is
proflowers.com all right?
So I've got to do is,
uh,
you want me to read their copy rather
than tell my silly little story. Hey,
everybody,
mother's Day is around the corner and
pro flowers always has great specials for
radio listeners.
Exclamation
point@profiles.com you will find
huge selections of Gorgeous,
Gorgeous Mother's Day bouquets
starting as low as 1999 plus.
You get a free vase with every, any
floral purchase. Isn't that great?
You get a free vase,
you know,
just lay it in her lap like she
just ran the fucking Kentucky Derby.
You know at that rate you can get
flowers for all the moms in your life,
your mother, your grandmother,
you assessed his mother.
I didn't make any sense. Your
girlfriend's mother, anybody,
any in your life you want to send flowers,
this is the website you go to.
All right?
If you want to call him up and he can
get this shit out of the way so you can
watch the Games,
the playoff hockey in the NBA,
all that call 800 pro flowers and
mentioned the Monday morning podcast.
Bill Burroughs say my name, so then I
get credit or better yet as they say,
go to pro flowers.com click on the
microphone in the top right hand corner.
That's a big thing. When you go to the
website, there's a microphone, right?
When you go to pro flowers, uh, and you
just get the upper right hand corner.
It says here about us on radio or TV.
Just click right there.
Then you type in the password.
Which of my last name? B. U. R. R,
pick out some flowers. Bangs on. They
fucking send it right to your house.
You hand it to your mother, you take
out a Ukulele, you get down on one knee,
you're singing your song and you're done.
The next thing you know,
you guys are both drinking booze, right?
There you go. See it wasn't that painless.
Told you a little funny story. I read the
copy. I got it out of the way. So Sarah,
see guys, if you want to
order those things, um, you
know, if you want to do it,
go to proflowers.com is a microphone
right in the corner. You Click on that,
you type in the password bur bur and
I'll actually get to goddamn credit.
All right, there you go. And with that,
let's get on with the podcast. All right.
That was like old school. The hosts of
the show was doing it like in the 1950s,
you know, this is the crest
toothpaste hour. Hello folks.
Say Your teeth falling out of your head.
Did you not notice?
Because you've been in a mine for the
last 20 years and you don't belong to a
union.
Thank God for crest.
It's got fluoride soon to
be in your drinking water.
So you're a lot more or less at days
lackadaisical or however you say the
fucking word and you're less
likely to question authority.
Um, I am in New York City people, uh, you
probably like, why bill, why are you in,
in New York City? I'll tell you why.
Uh, me and Joe de Rosa and Robert Kelly,
you heard last week we,
uh,
our film debuted in the prestigious
Tribeca film festival and uh,
I went to two of the screenings. I'm
going to another screening tonight and uh,
I gotta tell you something that is the
most nervous I've ever fucking been.
I'd have to go back to the first time I
did Letterman or maybe the first time I
even did stand up just the,
the feeling of,
of like,
what if this goes bad?
And I have absolutely no
control of it does. And uh,
fortunately it went well and uh,
I got up tell you something.
I don't say this too often. I was
really proud of, uh, I was proud of it.
You know,
I knew we didn't pull any punches,
but when I sought watching it with
the crowd was a whole different vibe.
Plus watching it up against
some of the other movies. Um,
you know, I was really nervous
cause their movies was, they were,
they were great and some were really
serious and I was just going, oh my God,
what the, how the hell is ours going to
hold up against in. Fortunately it did.
And,
uh,
we've had a great festival and tonight
is the last night and I gotta tell you
people,
I have never been more tempted to booze
since I quit booze and then this goddamn
week, but I got 200 days coming
up. I didn't want to fuck that up.
And then once I go over 200 days,
that's it. I'm just gonna fucking, uh,
I think I'm just going to pull myself
out, you know, like cal Ripkin.
I'm just going to say all right to
hell with this shit. You know? Fuck it.
What more do I need to prove?
So like I have a drinking problem.
I just have a huge head problems.
Do you guys know that?
That's really the real reason why I quit.
Not because I was getting drunk,
coming home, blaming my day on Nia,
slapping around a kitchen table and then
later taken out a fucking frozen box of
peas and putting it on the
side of her fucking left titty.
Cause I gave her a fucking
uppercut. Right? That's not why.
It's because I already have a giant head,
a pumpkin head,
as some of the people on
the Internet have said,
which always makes me giggle. Um, that's
why I quit drinking. I just got sick.
There's something like,
look, who's kidding? Who?
You hit middle age and I don't give
a fuck. You just don't look as good.
But there's no reason to help it along.
You know what I mean?
It's pure vanity. That's why I
fucking stopped. And uh, you know,
you know the deal, you know in the broads,
they fucking hit middle age. They've,
they've,
they've squeezed out a couple of fucking
kids now they resent the fuck anybody
who has free time,
you know,
because they made a decision to take a
hot one right between the fucking legs,
you know, that was your choice.
So I want to have a kid,
they're so cute and then they have one
and then there are a bunch of fucking,
it's mother's Day this week. Everybody,
let's not lose sight of that.
This is going to go bed. Uh, Jesus. Um,
yeah mothers are just,
they're fucking pains in the air.
Then another reason to go to pro flowers
and give him a bouquet and shove it in
their face. All right
already we got it. You agree?
You regretted your decision and I'm
a fucking reminder of it. So anyways,
um, I'm already picturing profile was
people listening to it that's just such,
lets you know, is this groundbreaking
way of selling flowers?
Cause it seems weird to me. Um, anyway,
I'll talk about how people age,
right? So what a women do. Okay.
Then they have a couple of kids and
they're so fucking God damn busy.
All right. That not only do they
not have time to do a sit up,
they don't even have time to
fucking wash their hair anymore.
So they all go out and get that Wayne
Gretzky haircut that he had when he got
married.
You know,
I'll show it on the side like Adolf
Hitler and then they poof it up on top.
You know, the Katie Lang, they get that
haircut and they're like, oh my God,
I love it. I love it. It's
so easy to deal with, right?
Not knowing that when their husband,
Ben's them over,
they feel like they're fucking a dude.
You know,
a dude with tits, right? That's what
you feel like. So that's how they age,
you know?
And then what happens with guys guys
age like John Travolta and Alec Baldwin.
It's very rare that a celebrity will
actually just continue to fucking eat and
booze and do what regular people do when
just allow themselves to age the way
regular people do. You know that
shit. You know that deal way? Uh,
I don't know. Eat like a pig all summer
and then it comes the wintertime.
You take out your button down shirt and
you got a t shirt on underneath it cause
you don't to sweat your way through it
cause you're such a fat fucking booze bag
at that point. And then you
just, you don't even notice.
And all of a sudden for
some reason you used to be,
you can only see a tee
shirt up top near your neck.
Now you can see it in between like each
button because the fucking fabric of
your button down is stretched.
So God damn far, that's why,
that's why I quit booze.
And I had, uh, you know,
every year I buy like four or five
button down shirts and those are my,
I'm going to headline for an hour doing
comedy shit, uh, shirts, right. And,
uh, they usually last me a year, but I
had this one and I didn't even notice.
You know, cause you know, you put
it on a couple of pounds a week,
you don't fucking know. It's all of a
sudden I was taking pictures and the,
and the button that was right,
you know,
between my man tits was
that the fabric was just,
it looked like the shirt was going to
explode. So that's basically why I,
uh, that's why I quit the
Busan. So, uh, I recommend it.
I recommend going off the
sauce for a minute. Um,
so now what I want to experiment
with as far as my boozing,
and I want to know if
there's anybody tried this,
I'm going to drink one day
a month and when I do, it's,
it's gonna be fucking epic.
I'm going to get it all out,
all out of the way in one day,
beer and whiskey all at the same time.
Giant chalices of fucking booze and a
then I'm going to hate myself for like a
day or two and then I'm just
going to get on with my month.
Has anybody been able to do that?
Because I tried doing that last time
and then it became a twice a month,
three times a month.
And next thing you know I'm
doing a fucking keg stand
and my face is turning red
and I'm just like, what am I doing? You
know, but I don't think I'm an alcoholic.
I just have a job where I can booze.
You know,
what's the worst that happens?
I show up,
hung over and I bitch about how I'm a
fucking loser and then everybody laughs
because they feel better about their
lives. Like he's doing worse than us.
This guy's awesome. So, uh, let
me know if you guys out there,
do you have any sort of, uh, do you
have any sort of, I don't know, like,
cause anybody been able to do
that? Like just say, I'm, I'm,
I only drink Saturdays or I
drink one Thursday a month.
Has anybody been able to stick with
that? I Dunno. That's my thing.
I'm afraid to go back to it because a,
I was really, I was looking like, well,
I don't look like a Baldwin, but my torso
did. You know I had the Baldwin Torso,
I the John Travolta Torso,
you know,
a Ted Kennedy Body. That's why the fuck
I was. Gino said that shit, by the way,
Bill Maher's in rolling stone this past
week and I read it and he said, how,
you know, he just sticks to weed and
they say, do you not like alcohol?
And he basically, I'm
paraphrasing here, he said he
loves it. He said, but as a guy,
after a while you just have to stop
drinking or you end up looking like Ted
Kennedy and it's fucking true.
Especially a white dude.
You get that WC fields knows,
hey, my little chickadee.
You don't want to look like that.
All right. You get the yellow eyes.
You get that fucking jaundice.
Oh God.
But I miss it. Um, anyways,
let's plow ahead here. Um,
so anyways, I was talking about my, uh,
can I say anyways any more
fucking times on this podcast. Um,
another thing that went on this week
is we had the second antisocial comedy
network show,
um,
that we did up at Foxwoods
in a 4,000 seat theater.
And we actually sold the thing out.
I was a absolutely blown away by not
only the amount of people showed up,
but how great the crowd was.
Everybody was talking about it.
For those of you who are on the outside,
the anti social network tours
put together by a Jim Norton,
little Jimmy from the wonderful
opie and Anthony Radio program.
Um, he put together this
towards me, Jim brewer,
Dave Attell and obviously Jim Norton.
And um,
we've been selling a ton of
tickets and it's been great.
Everybody does 20 minutes. We come out,
we hit you with our best stuff. And uh,
we kicked the shit out of
that crowd and they weren't,
they were just a great crowd. They
laughed. You could bring them up,
you could bring them down.
They were just a phenomenal crowd.
And then we just do a little question
and answering afterwards, I'm like,
five minutes. And then we hold ourselves
out afterwards, taking pictures,
signing shit. And everybody goes
back to gambling. And it was, uh,
just this amazing theater.
I was actually talking to brewer because
I'd had this fucking upper deck and we
immediately started talking about playing
wiffle ball and about whether or not
we could hit the upper deck from the,
uh,
from the stage man. And a, this one was,
it was just close enough where it
was a nice fucking poke. But, uh,
uh, Jesus, that would've
been a great time,
except the people who run the theater
would have thought it was obnoxious,
you know?
Yeah.
Look at these guys.
You get to tell jokes and play
wiffle ball with the fuck what next?
They can drink every night.
Uh,
but I want to thank everybody
who came down there and, uh,
if that tour interest you,
uh,
we've been selling a ton of tickets
down there and a Washington DC.
We're playing there on May 13th.
So get your fucking ass is down there.
All right,
look at it's so goddamn recession you
get for comics for the fucking price of
one. I am just whoring
myself out on this podcast.
proflowers.com now I'm hyping the tour
before I've even brought you an hour's
worth of comedy.
How fucking dare I look at me.
I'm becoming a corporate cont everything.
What were you guys do if I just totally
fucking sell out on this podcast?
I stopped saying cunt.
I actually build a cubicle around my bed.
I changed the name of the podcast.
This is brought to you by the Halliburton
Monday morning podcast that we do
every day now because the
higher ups are making us aid.
Do you know Halliburton actually
changed their fucking name? Um,
that was a weird way of saying, um,
uh, I was working down in Houston,
Texas and that's where they have, uh, at
least their United States headquarters.
And uh,
they used to have this giant sign as
you went to a George Bush international,
go fuck yourself. I love the
Illuminati airport down there. Um,
and they had this giant sign down there
that would say Halliburton and they had
such a bad public image is that they
actually made the sign a lot smaller and
they kept making it smaller and then now
they just finally changed their names
to like, uh, you know, grandma's
cupcakes or something like that.
Something just completely,
yeah. Pedestrian. Um,
you know, it's funny, I don't even
know what they do. Isn't that typical?
Isn't that just typical of
several whiny fucking cunt?
I have no idea what they even do.
What do they do?
What did they,
as far as I know,
this is my layman's understanding
of what they do is basically,
okay,
they say to the Pentagon, will you guys
blow it up? And then we'll rebuild it.
We'll get our contractors in there,
you know,
and we'll build a little strip mall.
We'll stick a Starbucks in there.
And that way everybody's
going to want to be American.
Everybody's going to want you don't
fucking fat. I feel right now.
I just went to a steak house and there
was these fucking real housewives chicks
sitting up at the bar.
These four white ladies,
you know, just dress like
horse. I'll tell you right now,
if you're a mom and you still dress like
you're out there trying to get fucked,
you're just a terrible mother,
you know, and they should really,
they should repossess your fucking kids.
And this is just going to all be about
mothers this week as I try to get you to
buy flowers.
You know,
what are you doing with the
tight fucking jeans? You know,
you're fucking Goddamn hip hugger jeans,
Goddamn c section scar just above
your badassador belts for fuck sakes.
Put some clothes on.
You're a mother. It's over.
You know, do you know I worked
with someone recently, right? And,
and they will fucking, you know,
they mentioned that they had a kid.
So I'm always asking about kids cause
I'm seriously thinking about having one,
you know, sticking him in the
corner next to a vase. You know,
just adding to like my, my
possessions. I'll have my guitars.
I've got a couple of guitars. What else
do I have? I don't know. A lot of shit.
I got a desk,
I'll stick in between the guitars and
the desk just that Monday they are.
And like,
you know when you have like those cakes
that they have under glass at diners,
I'll just a fucking baby in there.
Every once in awhile it
usually I'll lift the lid up
[inaudible] just
fucking put it back over, give
it a bottle, knock it off.
Hey,
knock it off,
visit awake and I'll just just tap on
the glass. That's really creepy. No,
I've been thinking about
having a kid. Right. So, um,
I ran into this mother after a show and
she was talking about her son and she
look young, right? She was like
30, 31 years old. And I go, uh,
I go, how old is your son? She goes, 11.
And then she mentioned she had a
daughter. I go, how was your daughter?
And she goes, 13. So I do the
math. She had him at 18 to 20.
And I was just like, Jesus
Christ. I, yeah, you started
young hunt. She winks at me.
She goes, yeah, got it out of the
way. She goes, now it's me time.
I'm just thinking in my head,
what do you mean me time there were 11
and 13 the fuck are you to, you know,
that's why I really think
it's a good thing that I,
I haven't had kids yet
because I'm a selfish cunt
and I'm really into doing shit
for myself. And it's just a lot
of people out there. I Dunno.
I think they just have kids
and then they that are all,
they stick them in front of the TV,
watch a little Teletubby, you know,
and they're just bad parents.
And then every once in a while you see
a great fucking parent who's really
involved with this kid. Like this youtube
video that somebody sent me this week,
this guy sent me a youtube video of
his seven year old son, uh, is a drama.
This kid is this shit. Not only can he
play, cause I've seen kids play before,
but he actually sings along with the
song and he has a lookup passion on his
face. It's fucking awesome. Uh, you
can watch all these videos, by the way,
on the [inaudible] podcast.com.
Um,
the only thing I will say to this to the
dad is you've got to get that kid some
sort of a, you got to get them
earplugs. You gotta get them those, uh,
those Vic first earphones
that you just put,
it looks like the kids get to use a
weed whacker. Just have them wear those.
It'll seem weird for the
first couple of days,
but I'm telling you that the kids ears
are going to be fucking junk if you let
him play without earplugs. Uh,
take it from me. I suffer from, uh,
tonight is a Tetnis,
however the fuck you say it.
And that's that ringing in
the year. Um, but you know,
there's nothing better than when you
actually see good parents. And I get it.
I get nervous, said I'm not going to
be a good dad. Um, and whenever I see,
you know,
whenever I see a bunch of fucking
women who are mothers just dressed like
they're out there looking to get banged,
it's just like,
there's no way you're a good mom.
You can't be a good mom.
You get dress too nicely.
You know, moms look,
they wear comfortable clothes.
They have that fucking look on
their face like Jesus Christ.
What did I do with my life?
That's a mom.
You got sit down there with Ed Hardy
panties and then going out? Yeah,
my, my dad or just graduated
the seventh grade. Really?
The fuck are you doing?
What are you out here riding on the
back of the Harley with your Goddamn ass
crack showing you're
not a mom right there.
You ought to get a warning. You know, you
should get a warning dress like a mom.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Sitting here drinking your God damn
booze in the middle of the day.
How would your Bra straps showing
the fuck is wrong with you lady?
Uh, am I wrong thinking that? Am I
just being selfish? Because you know,
when I become a dad,
I still want to have a cool car.
I don't have that fucking van. I
wouldn't have a car. That's cool.
And my kids aren't allowed in it. And
when they asked me why, I'm going to say,
because at your age you're still
a fucking animal. Look at you.
You got cheerios all over your face.
You got ice cream on your fingers.
I don't even remember.
You have an ice cream.
What is that shit you think you're
going to get my dodge fucking challenge.
I'm just going to have one nice car.
That's going to be for me and Nia
when we go out and we get a sitter,
right? That's, that's the uh,
let's pretend we don't have responsibility
car and we'll go out and have a
dinner and come back in a couple hours
and then we'll just have some shit
fucking van,
uh,
Shit van with those fucking Nascar
Formula One seat belts that criss cross in
front of you, both for safety and also
so those little bastards can't get up.
You know,
I still think I'm going to be a good dad
despite the horrific shit of sand right
now.
Um, somebody sent me a great, oh, by
the way, my specialists still showing,
still streaming on Netflix, by
the way. I want you guys' opinion.
I'm thinking the next time I do a special,
I'm sending my special directly to
Netflix because I think when I sent it to
channels where they have
commercials and they censor it,
you're not getting the re the full on
ignorant Bill Burger experience are you,
you know, it just, you know,
you really want to see the
level of more on that. I am.
You have to have the uncensored version.
So I'm thinking that that's the future.
I'm loving it because people will watch
Netflix or are there if they seem like
they're getting the real special to me,
which means they either absolutely love
it or they think I'm the dumbest person
on the planet. Uh, with that, let's
get into advice for this week.
This podcast is going to be a little
shorter than the recently I've been doing
like an hour and 20. I think
they're too fucking long. Um,
so I'm going to try and do about an hour.
Come right in and about an hour.
You know, let's just long
enough for your commute. Um,
Oh, before I read the advice that
I'd tell you guys, I'm working,
I'm trying to work on my temper now
that I got the booze on the control,
uh, and now I'm going to
work on my temper. See,
this is me slowly giving into the fact
that I'm going to get married at some
point. I can't even say that
I'm going to get married.
Then I'm going to get married at some
point. I'm going to have kids. All right.
First thing I had to do is I had to stop
drinking. Like I was pledging a frat.
That was the first fucking
thing I had to do. You know?
Although when I have kids,
I'm going to be really tempted at the
end of my long workday doing absolutely
nothing as a comedian,
you know,
not to just pour that scotch with
the one fucking ice cube in it.
I don't want to do that in front of kids.
Maybe I'll have a shed out back.
Okay.
And that's what I'll do. All my Busan.
Right. And then eventually, you know,
I'll think that I'm fooling everybody and
then I'll have a bottle in the back of
the fucking half bathroom in the basement,
you know,
in the back of the toilet.
Then everybody had no on Busan.
And then eventually when they have the
intervention will be out there in that
shit.
Bill thinks he's doing a documentary and
I'm going to be fucking sitting there a
walk in. This is why I do most of my
drinking and I'll be all noble about it.
I never do it in front
of my kids. You know, my,
my kids fear everything could be, you
know, eventually I'm going to stop, right?
And then I go walking in there.
My whole disappointed family's going
to be sitting there next to a band saw.
And I'm a stubborn Irish mother fucker.
I'm not going to rehab. Go Fuck Yourself.
You go to Rehab. Oh, we're all
walking out. God, more booze.
Money for me.
Um,
I ain't know what the hell
I'm talking about right now.
Have you guys been watching
the playoff hockey?
Congratulations to everybody's team
or moved on to San Jose Sharks.
The Detroit Redwings, the Nashville
predators. Who would've thought, oh,
what a fuck it thought. Who the hell are
they playing out? Their kings are out.
Ducks are out. Oh, Vancouver, Vancouver.
And then over in the east to one cheese.
I don't know who wants series last week.
A Tampa Bay lightning,
Washington capitals,
Philadelphia Flyers.
And I think that's it. I think that's
the, uh, those are, oh, wait a minute.
Oh,
Jesus.
I almost forgot the Boston
Bruins beat the fucking fuck.
Fucking fucking Montreal Canadians. Oh,
was that enjoyable?
What a tremendous series.
Round of applause for playoff hockey.
It went seven games.
Like you knew what was gonna and I
thought it was a tremendous series,
although I was a little disappointed
with the certain members of the Montreal
Canadians with that bitch level of hockey,
that fucking
Hammer Lik Jesus Christ.
I thought he was in some fucking slap
stick movie. What was he doing out there?
Anytime you went,
move fucking skate,
the wind of you skating by the
guy would just fall down of funny.
Was that when, what's his
face? The Bruins announcer.
I can never remember his name. John,
whatever. When he fucking Egos here,
Millette goes down like
he was shot jet up.
I'm not a fan of that over the top
sort of fucking announcing, but I,
that was so fucking called for when he
said that it was fucking ridiculous.
But uh,
but it was just a,
it was a phenomenal series
and I knew it was going seven,
seven games and I was
hoping we were going to win.
I'm not even going to talk shit, you
know, I'm not even going to talk shit.
Whenever you play the Canadians, they
have fans, even if their team sucks,
they take them to the next level was
a fucking awesome series. And uh,
that fucking sue bond guy man is the shit.
That guy is a star.
And I loved the way he plays the game.
I even love that annoying shit. He does.
I love it.
He's a Gamer.
He's just trying to knock you off your
fucking game by being a cunt. I love it.
And he can play the game.
And that fucking goal that he scored
to send it into overtime was, uh,
there was just a fucking laser beam.
But I gotta tell you,
there is some sort of unwritten NHL rule
that if the Montreal Canadians are down
by a goal in a deciding game,
I don't give a fuck whether
you committed a penalty or not.
You're going to be short
a man. They just, I mean,
how many fucking years in a row can they
do that for that team? It's ridiculous.
Wasn't it enough that for
all those fucking decades
they got first shot at every
French born Canadian player?
Wasn't that enough that they got,
they had their own draft pool.
It has six team league this so fucking
overrated with their goddamn history.
And I love that.
When Bruins fans talk to him
now all Canadian fans have
is their history. What's,
what's the historical playoff
series record? Yeah, that's right.
Go back a quarter to
have a fucking century.
Since the last time you dominated us, you
fucking French cunts. You got nothing.
You haven't dominated
us since 1987 it's over.
It's fucking over now. If you want
to trash us for not winning a cup,
I don't have a dog in that fight.
We're fucking horrific. It's pathetic.
We haven't won in one in almost 40 years.
You're 100% in the right.
But if you're going to try and sit
there and act like your in the way,
you're not. Go do your fucking
homework there. Frenchie all right,
we've played you guys 11 times since
1988 we beaten you seven fucking times.
Have four and seven against us.
We'd beat you in a seven game series.
We'd beat you all three overtime
games and last time we played you,
we swept you when the
last two games at home.
So I don't know what the fuck you're
talking about and Dan Shaughnessy you lazy
mother fucker. If you're not going to
watch hockey, stop writing about it.
You know that son of a bitch
when we want to game seven,
he still figured out a way to shoehorn
in the curse of the Babe Horse that he
always writes about.
There's nothing funnier than watching
Dan Shaughnessy writing about hockey.
He knows nothing about it. He started
bringing up Johnny Pesky, you know,
ted Williams.
Bucky Dent.
He then the man can only write one
fucking story if there's not a ghost,
a Goblin or a or in it. He doesn't
know how to write the fucking article.
You know, it's fucking ridiculous. Why?
Why don't you address the real problems,
Dan Shaughnessy like how the Bruins
resented free agency. Not only didn't,
didn't play the game,
they fucking resented it.
They didn't want to fucking pay anybody.
Why don't, why don't you talk about that?
Or the Canadians drafting first pick
of every French born Canadian player.
Why don't you bring shit up like that
as opposed to sounding like you're
pitching a show to go on
after ghost hunters. Oh,
somebody get that guy a hot comb and
a fucking book on Goddamn hockey.
All right, let's plow
ahead here. Um, advice,
advice for the week. Um, oh
wait, I promise these guys.
I was going to read it.
Now that I've said con 20 times,
I promise that I was going to read this
thing three times during the podcast.
So we're at the halfway point.
Everybody open yourself up a beer.
Go sharpen a fucking pencil at your
cubicle or whatever the hell it is you do
there. Once again, people, Mother's
Day is this Sunday. All right,
don't be a Douche.
Just go to proflowers.com.
Click on the microphone in the upper right
hand corner when you type in the code.
Uh, right. B U. R. R. So I get credit on
my podcast and just order some flowers.
You'll get a vase,
you get the whole damn thing.
And then I got to do is take her out to
the IHUB. You know, you get some pancakes.
What does she like?
Eggs benedict. You know,
just do something like that or
have you fucking broad do it.
But this is the thing.
Look,
if you're a lazy bastard and you want
to look like a good shit this year,
you could bang it all out.
You go right to pro flowers
by some for your mother.
Buy some for your girlfriend's mother
and buy some for your grandmother.
All right? Then everybody in your life
with a vagina can shut the fuck up.
Four o'clock man. Seriously? You know
what I mean? Guys, we don't like to shop.
I should really stick to the copier.
Mother's Day is right around the corner.
Everybody in pro flowers
has mother's Day bouquets.
starting@nineteenninetyninevisitproflowers.com
clip
on the
mic.
Click on the microphone in the top right
hand corner and type in my password.
B U. R. R, get her a bouquet of flowers.
Get her a Goddamn vase handed to her,
telling her lover she's only going to be
around for so goddamn long. You know it.
I know what you should be doing this
every damn year, every fucking year.
All right? You go there.
You take her out to Denny's,
you know plural, Pura Bulla,
corn flakes at that point.
If you've got the fucking
flowers and the vase.
Don't be a cheap acid on this one. You
got to get the base too. Like I said,
don't lay it in her lap like she
just wrote a fucking horse. Okay?
You get a vase,
you know women shit.
Alright,
and vase is, it's just another thing.
Oh my God, he got a vase with it.
He really does love me. All right, that's
the commercial at the half hour seat.
Look at this. Look at this. I'm getting
the information in. I'm keeping it funny.
I'm still saying cunt. It's
just phenomenal. All right.
Uh, advice for this week.
Dearest bill, my entire life, I've jumped
from one long relationship to another.
Oh, geesh. At the ripe age of 30,
I've started to see a pattern.
Good for you. There you go. That's
right. You've seen a pattern.
Now see people, this is how you improve
your life rather than blaming others.
It's like being a comedian.
How many times can you bomb
and say in this crowd sucks.
At some point you've got to look at
yourself. You gotta you gotta look,
go to the mirror and look
at your fucking booze bag.
Freckled face like me a few
months ago and say, listen,
I've got to lay off the booze. I gotta
I gotta I gotta work on my act here. Um,
so this is what this guy's doing.
Exactly.
You keep pulling fish out of the same
poison pond and you getting tired of it.
Good for you, sir. Here's
the pattern. He goes,
I start when I start dating a woman,
she's dialed up.
She's in great shape.
She's fun to be around.
She's always willing to go the extra
mile by doing little things to show you.
She cares and she's willing to explore,
enjoy,
and share my interests.
All right.
Starting off a little myopic. She
dresses nice in lights to do this shit.
I though, all right. After a few
months, one year or two, one year,
she does up about 50% of the time.
She's still in good shape.
She's fun to be around.
She's a willing,
she's willing to explore
and share my interests.
One year on little by little,
things start to disappear.
She does up 10% of the time.
She's an average to pudgy shape.
She's fun about half the time and she's
only the willing to share interests
there are that are already developed.
Oh,
so she doesn't want to do any new things.
Each girl seems to stray further and
further away from their month one
personalities at different rates.
Yet it,
it seems to always stray away into the
negative zone. Oh, it never gets better.
I again find myself in a new
relationship, things that, okay,
so he gets out of that one.
One year in he goes, hey again,
find myself in a new relationship.
Things are fan fucking tastic.
I'm living the dream yet I
find myself terrified. Oh,
so I guess he's in a new relationship.
When will she stop dialing up?
When will she stop being easygoing?
When will that little pouch start to grow
above her belt? I'm jaded and scared.
Bill.
Does the month one girl ever stick around?
Am I doing something to turn these perfect
girls into comfortable couch potatoes?
I don't want to see another
one transformed. What do I do?
I know it's human nature to
get comfortable, comfortable,
sooner or later to be able to
function as a normal human being.
It's impossible to keep
that one month girl around,
but can't they just stay in the one month,
a year category? Do they have to go beyond
the one year? Oh, as far. And he said,
okay, am I ready to get billed?
Burned. People liked that one.
I forget what the other one was.
It was a wait,
I got it here at the
top of the page. Uh, ah,
ginger or odd ginger. Snap. Um,
those are my catch phrases.
Everybody. Um, all right,
let's plow ahead here. Uh, what
am I up to? Oh, by the way,
I'm probably going to forget this.
So if my web guy is listening,
please remind me to put up the
youtube videos of that red headed kid.
There's some poor bastard. This kid, I
don't know how old he is. He's like 12,
13 years old and he makes
these videos and he's just,
he doesn't know any better.
He lives in the middle of nowhere.
He's just making a total ass of himself.
So every time he, and he's a redhead,
you know,
he's already in an awkward age and he's
a red head and he's a redhead mail. So,
you know, that's just a fucking
hail storm. I lived through it.
It's not a pretty sight.
San Jose sharks go up to nothing. Sorry,
got the game on in the background.
Um, so anyways, yeah, that's,
that's not a fun time.
It's not a fun time for fucking
anybody unless you know,
you're just one of the popular kids.
So this kid keeps making these videos.
So what happened was,
was people started trashing them
because that's what happens. You know,
you put yourself out there,
you basically,
the second you get on a stage or you
film yourself, you've, you basically,
you put yourself on a Dunkin stool and
given the world a bunch of baseballs,
that's basically what you've done.
This kid didn't realize it,
so they start fucking trash in them.
And rather than ignoring it,
he's been responding to it and
he's yelling into the camera.
This is a message for
all you haters out there.
I can make as many videos as I want,
but all going to continue making videos.
So fuck you.
He's doing that. And he has faces
all fucking freckled and red.
He looks like a young Malakai from church,
children of the corn.
He sings songs. Um, actually
I got a name, a name here,
a Aziz from a parks and recreation
was down. Uh, I gotta give him,
I gotta give him credit a Aziz and sorry,
Gee,
he hooked me up with these videos.
He goes, you got to check these out.
Cause I was telling him,
you got to watch that guy at the del
Taco who gets knocked out three fucking
times in this battle. Royal.
Um, so whatever, see, we got, I,
I'm hyping that video and I hope that I
remember, uh, to tell my web guy about it.
If not,
I hope he's listening to this podcast
and they put it up cause it's fucking
hilarious. So anyways, let's
get back to this guy. Um,
he basically asked me how do I, how does
somebody stay in the one month thing?
Well, let me ask you this, sir.
How do you do over the year?
Do you put on any weight?
What are you, do you know?
This is the thing about relationships
that I learned is that they're fucking
work.
And it's what you're discovering is that
what happens is you meet somebody and
yeah, it's exciting. It's new. It's like
a, I don't know, you go on vacation,
so he never been to Miami.
You go to Miami Beach,
it's going to be fucking exciting.
All right. He got another vacation.
You go to Miami beach again.
It's still exciting,
but it's not quite as you keep
fucking doing the same thing.
It's just natural that you start taking
things for granted and it works on both
sides.
Um,
what I would do is if you want your girl
to stay in shape is I would keep myself
in shape and uh,
I,
if you're into a girl that stays in shape
and there's nothing wrong with that,
by the way,
there's always on those women's shows
that that's superficial and blah, blah,
blah, and guys should
look beyond it. Fuck you.
You're lazy and you want to eat ice
cream and you still want to get the same
amount of love like you, like you
have an hourglass figure, you know,
that's just women pimping guys. Okay.
If you want a woman who's in shape,
why don't you fucking date someone who
likes to work out? That's what I would do.
Who's into that type of shit? Who to
considers that type of thing important.
That's what I would do.
And then you kept saying shit
like she's willing to explore,
enjoy and share my interest.
Well that's all well and good.
As long as you're willing to do it
with her. And also I would say that,
you know,
you know what's a great thing to do
in a relationship is to have interests
outside of the other person.
And the two of you fuck off for for
an hour or two every day. You know,
like I can tell you if
I'm in a relationship,
all right. And I joined a
gym. I don't want my, I don't,
I don't want my girl joining
the same fucking gym. I don't,
I want two hours by myself. Who's kidding?
Who, 20 minutes on the treadmill and be,
ah, lift weights tomorrow or
whatever, say like an hour to myself.
I listen to my music, you
know, I'm looking at at the,
at the fucking ass and titties of other
girls, right? That's legal, you know,
they're walking around in their
sports bras. I can do that, you know,
listen to my ACDC fucking get
pumped, lie to myself, like,
dude of the summer on putting up to 25
kid fucking two plates on both sides
stowed. I could lie to myself,
you know, but I definitely think,
uh, look, I would just say, you
know, the next time you're, you're,
you're tell, tell your girl
that's, that's, that's your
fear said, yeah, look, I,
I just keep being in these relationships
and everything just sort of winds down
everybody, you know, people are in good
shape. I went, you know, I don't know.
That's kind of a tough thing to say,
to be like,
are you going to become a fatty
in a year? Um, I don't know, Dude.
You ever thought about just being single
and just tagging a bunch of chicks who
were in shape and every night
will be exciting and new.
Come aboard.
I'm expecting you.
So ride my single fucking Goddamn cock.
Um, every, evidently the way you can get
herpes while still wearing a condom is,
is I guess that the,
uh,
the party at Dick that's behind the
Maginot line there basically the part,
you know, you put a condom
on, you roll it down.
You always have it at fucking
three quarters mass, don't you?
Even if you stretch it all the way down,
it doesn't fucking cover your whole Dick.
There's always going to be the Goddamn Ma,
you know,
eighth of an inch of shaft.
You know,
unless you got a huge fucking Dick and
you bought the wrong condoms and half
your dicks hanging out,
hanging out. Right.
And the condoms on top of your head and
you have Dick looks like fucking Arnold
from happy days. Remember that?
Had he used to wear or big al?
Um, I guess that's how you can
get it. I don't fucking know.
I don't want to hear about STDs.
It just makes me happy.
I'm going to fucking relationship, you
know. Um, anyways, let's plow ahead here.
Next, next question here. Next
fucking question. Uh, Bill,
big fan of your comedy podcasts.
Listen to it every Tuesday on the way
home while I'm stuck in traffic. Anyway,
here's my deal. I moved to
us in order. I just realized,
I forgot to tell you guys
how I'm working on my temper.
I decided to break it up into chunks
rather than just trying not to lose my
shit. I just realized I gotta I,
I just got to attack it and chuck,
so this is how I'm trying to do it.
I'm just working on my temper in the car.
That's it.
And I've been meaning to get a post it
and I'm just going to draw a smiley face
on it and just stick it on the dashboard.
That's what I'm trying to do.
And I did it this morning.
I was able to do it.
I was returning a rental car and uh,
you know, it's Sunday morning,
I get up, I jump in the car,
Ford Fusion, great fucking car
to man getting this car. And I,
uh, they should be no traffic.
I should just shoot right up,
get the car back by nine 30 so I
don't have to pay for the extra day.
And what happens, there's all this
construction and I got to admit,
it took me a while to lose my shit,
but when the fucking Douche cut
into my lane, I, that was it.
I just fucking without
even thinking, just, just
[inaudible],
just
pushing down on the horn and a,
when I stopped, I was like, oh fuck.
I lost my temper. I guy, I gotta,
I gotta stop and then somebody else did
something and I fucking laid on the horn
twice. So, so I failed.
You know what the fuck that's off sides
through the officiating has just sucked
in the NHL,
this whole fucking place.
How bad were the fucking calls first
game? Uh, on both sides, by the way.
On both sides. At least. That first
period is what I really watched, um,
of the, uh, Bruins flyers by the
way, which is by the time I, uh,
you listened to this podcast,
let's do it on Tuesday.
That series is going to be one,
one going back to Boston.
I think this is going to
be a great series. Uh,
and I think it's going to be one of those
series where, yeah, I dunno. It's weird.
The Bruins are weird.
They're just on their game right now.
But when they're not on their
game, they, they just, I dunno.
It's like they're playing the
fucking ice out in the ice.
Capades so I don't know.
I'm nervous about that happening.
And I also with the flyers
did to us last year,
but the thing is is the flyers have
no fucking goaltending as a right now.
So, uh, Tim Thomas is
just fucking ridiculous.
So I think we're going to win the series.
I actually think we might take it
in six games. If we win game two,
we went into six. If they win game
two, uh, this fucker's going seven.
That's my prediction. Everybody, for
those of you want, don't watch hockey,
you probably don't give a
shit to you. All right, Bill,
big fan of your comedy podcasts. Let's do
it every Tuesday and the way they work.
Anyway, here's my deal. I moved to Austin,
Texas about three fucking
years ago because of a job
I had just broken up with a
long time on again, off again, girlfriend,
and was finally done
with the relationship.
I made the decision to be single for
a while and enjoy the single life in
Austin. Worked out well,
but I soon meadow lane,
she turned out to be the girl from
me and I was soon shopping for rings.
So we're getting married in the fall.
Congratulations.
And I moved in about six months ago.
You see,
my girl is a real hard
worker as am I. Uh, Jesus.
Crisis is fucking long.
Settle in everybody.
No one has ever given us anything in life.
And we both worked hard to earn what
we have. And because of our hard work,
we both have successful careers,
careers.
My Boston accent just came
out their successful careers.
So she's busted her ass through college,
got a job, and bought a house in her own.
Impressive because she was only
24 at the time. God Damn it.
I wish I lived in Texas and could buy a
house at 24 middle of fucking nowhere.
Anyways, and since then we have worked
hard to make it a home together.
All sounds good, right? Yeah, that sounds
great. Well there is a catch. Oh Jesus.
Here we go.
She has this friend who she's known since
childhood and they grew up together.
This sounds like a fucking
romantic comedy. They are like
sisters, blah, blah, blah.
She let her friend move into
the house before we met. Oh No.
And was barely charging
the girl rent at all.
She also had her sister moving, but as
soon as we decided to live together,
as sister moved out, like a
normal fucking person. Anyways,
so this friend of hers is
still living in the house.
Even six months after we got
engaged and moved in together.
Not only did she stay,
she also had her boyfriend move in while
living there and while living there she
bought a cat and a dog. Well,
I mean, what the fuck dude?
How come you're not saying anything?
Oh, well here's the next sentence.
I had a million talks with my girl about
it and how it's wildly inappropriate to
have these people and animals living in
our house when we're trying to start a
family,
but she feels responsible
for the wellbeing of her
friend and doesn't want to
throw her out on her ass.
Oh No.
Okay.
Holy Shit Dude. How big
is this house? Anyways,
eventually I talked to my girl and just
sitting down with her friend and her
boyfriend and kindly tell them it's time
to start looking for another place to
live.
They agreed and everything was all good,
so three months later the friends still
doesn't have a job and her boyfriend is
only working part time.
As far as I can tell,
they haven't started looking
for jobs or a place to live.
I've heard her complaining to my girl
about not wanting to sign a lease on a
dump because she is planning on getting
a job and we'll be able to afford a
nicer place soon. Yeah, she's
stringing you along. It's bullshit.
She's the laziest bitch I ever met.
Sounds like a dude.
The way you're describing and I already
hate her. I'm coming home every work day.
Uh, I'm going wrong for work
everyday. And her boyfriend,
her and her boyfriend are sitting
on the couch playing video games.
Oh my God.
I also recently found out that my girl
is not charging her friend any rented all
and that boyfriend only pays 200 a month,
which is nothing compared to what he could
be making with the fuck what we could
be making with the roommate.
And he's a fucking loser as well.
30 years old and never had
a fulltime job in his life.
He brags about not having
any debt all the time,
but it's because he's a loser and he's
been living off his girlfriend's student
loans and my girls kindness
for the past two years.
Okay.
Do I have to read the rest of this?
Let me blow through the last
two paragraphs in Murcia
[inaudible] and this thing,
people try to keep the shortage.
I suck at reading here. Um,
I would be constantly bitching
about these people to my girl,
but it kills her to,
to know,
okay
that I'm not happy.
She spends a lot of time trying
to make my life better and I can,
I really can't stand to
see her sad or frustrated.
She stuck in a tight spot.
Yeah.
Do the same thing she's doing with
you that she hates to see you,
not happy and she wants to keep you happy.
She's still in that with her friends.
She has to make a stand here.
So he says, so to make a point,
I've been leaving my
stuff out in the kitchen,
in the living room and not cleaning up
after myself and in front of everybody.
I tell my girlfriend to
leave it that she should,
that they should have to clean it up
because we're doing them a favor for
letting them live there.
I've pretty much been a cock sucker
openly to them everyday for the last three
months. But they haven't gotten the hint.
Yeah, they have their fucking dead beats.
So just ignoring it.
So anyways,
but me behaving like that makes my
girlfriend uncomfortable. Comfortable too.
So I backed off a bit.
So the latest is that they finally are
starting to pick up on the fact that we
want them out in or making
provisions to move out.
But I've recently found out that they
are planning on moving in with my girl's
mom just down the street.
Her mom's thinks of the friends is a
daughter or a good family friend in is
allowing this.
This pisses me off because I know they're
just going to mooch off from mom just
like they did my girl. So now I know
I'm planning on having another talk. No,
don't do that.
Don't do that.
So now I'm planning another talk with
them about starting their own life
separate from my girl or her family.
But I know they wouldn't get the message
unless they came out and became a
complete Dick, which would totally
killed my girlfriend. What should I do?
This is what you do. Alright. Um,
let him move into your, my girlfriend's
mom's house. Let them fucking do it.
Get it out of your house. All
right? Eventually there will they,
they will wear out their welcome at your
mom's house and then they're gone. It's,
it's,
but the thing is right now is if you,
if you tell her mom that they fucking
dead beats in that type of shit,
[inaudible] if you'll either come
off like a dick or she'll say,
well then to hell with it,
they're not moving in. And
then there'll be like, well,
we can move out of your place and now
you're stuck with them. All right?
You have the things that wouldn't
leave in your fucking house and they're
leaving. Let them leave. Let them go
down to your sister's mom's house.
This is probably where your, you, you,
I mean your girlfriend's mom's house.
This is probably where she learned
that fucking behavior from, you know,
so that's her house right now.
What it is,
is you personally hate these motherfuckers
and you want them to live in this
shithole that they so
rightfully deserve to live in.
So what you're doing right
now is you're letting your,
your personal hatred of them get
in the way of your ultimate goal,
which is to get them the fuck out of
the house, which is happening, okay?
If her mother wants to take them in,
let her do it,
and eventually she will discover
that they're fucking mooches.
Now I know what you're thinking. Like
what kind of a fucking future son in law,
my, if I don't give her the
heads up, and I'm telling you,
just judging by the way
your future bride is,
this is just how they are.
They're giving people who get
taken advantage of by mooches.
And the same way your fiance
is learning this lesson,
your mother's going to learn the lessons.
So these people are actually great that
they came into your life because the,
hopefully you'll be able to use them as
an example, all throughout your marriage,
whatever their fucking names are.
You going to be like, well look,
we're going to end up in another situation
like Kathy and Michael. Fuck face.
Remember that when they sat on the goddamn
couch playing Atari for three fucking
years? Um, yeah, dude, listen,
you don't want to fight both those fights.
You'll end up like America.
You going to have two wars going on
at once. You're going to go bankrupt.
Don't do that shit. All right.
[inaudible] is your house.
Let him go to fucking Afghanistan. Don't
fucking worry about it. Or vice versa.
We went into Afghanistan first. I don't
know how to fucking say it. I don't read.
I don't give a shit a Douche
bag of the week, by the way,
is Hammernik from fucking the Canadians.
That guy's an all star man.
He knows better than that.
Flopping around out there like he's
on Fucking, I love Lucy or something.
Doing a good Carol Burnett show.
Doing a goddamn sketch.
Jared up. All right, last
one. I'm going to read here.
Everybody coming up on an hour keeping
this one nice and tight. Hey Bill,
I love you. Stand up comedy on your
podcasts are freaking hilarious.
Thank you very much. I love what you're
doing and I hope you keep doing it, bro.
Log [inaudible] thank you.
I'm a junior in high school and I really
have a problem with my mom's boyfriend.
Uh, yes, I would think so
for the obvious reasons,
but we're not going to get into that
because you're too young to talk about it.
I don't know what to do because my mom
used to be really cool and she would
really listen to me when her boyfriend
wasn't around. Now when he comes over,
she makes,
she makes me Cook my own dinner,
which isn't that bad to do,
but the fact that she ignores
me and listens to him more
than she does to me is
what really gets to me.
This guy can be a real asshole to
me and my mom, oh Jesus Christ.
And the thing is that they fight all
the time and yet they're still together.
After five years, you can tell
a Douche bag when you see one,
and this guy really takes the trophy of
number one douche bag in the country.
All right,
you know what?
Fuck that Douche bag of the week
is the due date in this kid's mom.
He even yells at my mom's sometimes and
I felt the urge to confront him one time
and my mom is the one who gets mad
at me for trying to defend her.
I feel like this guy has
changed my mom from a nice,
cool mom to one of those reality show
moms who don't really give a shit about
their kids. Yeah. See this
is why you gotta be careful
who you let into your life.
This guy has kids and he treats them
way worse than he treats my mom.
I feel really bad for his kids for
having such a bad father figure in their
lives. Yeah. This guy's
horrific. He's now,
he's never gotten violent
with my mom I think,
but I think my mom has gotten dependent
on him for some fucked up reason. Yeah.
Cause he's probably doing that.
He's working on a self esteem.
He probably criticizes the shit out of
her and he's turned a nice, positive,
great mom into a negative person who's
not paying attention to our kid. Yeah.
She's got a dump.
This guy,
and I'm pretty sure it's taken a toll
on what my mom is like as a person.
I have no idea what my mom sees in him
because they have practically nothing in
common and he's a total asshole to her.
And to me what I really need his advice
on how I can handle this situation,
what I can do to make this situation
better for me and my mom besides choking
this in the middle of the night.
I would really appreciate
some sound advice from you,
even though you don't have kids.
I would also like to know if you were
doing any gigs or any shows around
southern California, because I really
like to see in person. Thanks bill.
All right. This is what you gotta
do. All right. This is very tricky.
One of the hardest things to do is when
somebody you love is dating an asshole
to approach them and say,
Hey,
I think the person you're dating is an
asshole because they're going to get
unbelievably defensive. All right?
So I would leave that part out of it.
What I would do is when that
Douche bag isn't around,
I would basically tell your mom what you
told me, minus the bad shit about him.
Just say, listen. You know,
I just feel like you know,
you're not listening to me as much
as you used to tell your lover.
Tell her she's the greatest mom.
And just,
just tell her that you felt like you
used to be closer and that you're feeling
like you're not as close as you
used to be and that you know,
you realize that you're her time
with their boyfriend is important.
But I'd like to have a whatever schedule,
schedule some hang time with you guys.
And you know what,
when you guys are out there having a
good time, maybe she can, you know,
slowly turn into that
person she used to be.
And then eventually you kind of trick
her into talking about that guy and let
her be the first one. This is, this is
down the road. Let her, once you guys,
you know, have your hang day, you
know, and I'll tell you right now, if,
if that guy gets in the way,
which you probably will try to,
cause he sounds like an insecure douche
bag that if you guys are actually
hanging out,
you know there's a lot of like little
Mussolini's run around the world.
They just don't have the fucking charisma
and the right cataclysmic moment in
history to take power. So what they
do is rather than ruining countries,
they just ruined families. Every one
that they come in contact with. So this,
that's what this cost is like.
And he'll probably try and take that
time away from you guys because he'll be
convinced because in the back of his head,
I bet he knows he's a fucking asshole.
Um,
or he's a paranoid psycho and he thinks
everybody's talking about them anyways,
which of course you attract what
you fear in life. So I think,
uh, just keep it about you and
her. Tell her how great she is.
Mother's Day is coming up. It's
perfect. And just say, listen, you know,
I'm getting older. These next few
years are going to fly by. You know,
I'd like to take advantage of this time.
Let's spend time together. You know,
just you and me.
Like we used to just one day a week.
I respect your time with your boyfriend,
but you know,
one day a week I'm your son for Christ
sake. We could do this. And like I said,
during that time, um, that
Douche won't be around.
It'll be just the two of you.
I bet the old her comes out a little bit.
If you do it once a week, it's
like therapy. And like I said,
eventually you let you
let her bring it up,
let her bring up with that
guy's an asshole. You know,
he's kind of been a dick,
you know what I mean? He just kind
of sit there like, yeah, yeah,
I don't know what you mean. And just
respectfully call the guy and asshole.
And as far as choking that guy in the
middle of the night, don't do that now.
Don't do that. Wait till you
like high school years. You know,
wait til you hit your growth spurt.
You know, you start filling out,
you start throwing the weights around.
That's when you do it. You know,
take a nice karate class. Go with the
submission whole, that's what I would do.
You know, you choke them out.
They just go to sleep. You know,
there's no concussion, there's nothing
like, he just, he just takes a little nap.
I'm not advocating violence. Wink, wink.
I'm all right. Youtube videos a week.
That's going to be the
podcast for this week.
Here's a youtube videos for this week.
Um,
I already hyped that amazing seven
year old drummer. Fucking awesome. Uh,
these are all going to
be on the MN podcast.com,
the official fan page of the Monday
morning podcast if you'd like to donate.
All right,
uh,
to the podcast is that donate button
right on the right hand side of the
homepage, right underneath the
Facebook, Twitter and all those logos.
You just click on donate, whatever you
want to give me. I don't give a fuck $1,
1000. I don't give a shit. I'll
fucking take any of it. Um,
and anyways, all these youtube
videos, we'll be up there. Next one,
greatest dance number ever
filmed according to Fred Astaire,
who was considered the greatest
dancer of that time. But, uh,
he was a phenomenal dancer,
but he was also a white dude.
So he had an advantage like the Montreal
Canadians getting first pick of every
French born Canadian fucking player.
Um,
that's what white people were in Hollywood
back then. Uh, but during this time,
you know, and this is this, I think this
is really cool that Fred Astaire said,
this shows you what a cool guy. This
was. This guy was that he gave a,
he gave a shout out to the uh, Jesus
Christ. Where the fuck's the video?
Now what did I do? Oh
Christ, what did I do?
That's not the right one.
As fucking hang on a second.
The hell did I do here?
All right. Greatest. The Nicholas
Brothers hope I'm saying that right.
You got to watch this video.
Even if you don't like all those fucking,
so you think you can dance.
So you think you can do a split
naviat twat stick to the floor.
You know when I'll be the judge of that.
If you don't like those fucking shows,
you got to watch these guys.
These guys are unbelievable.
It's called the greatest dance
number ever filmed at the beginning.
You're probably not going to like it.
Cab Calloway's in their scat singing.
I fucking hate [inaudible]
singing. I, I just don't like it.
I don't think it's a talent skill.
But at beam apple on abdomen dead baby,
shut your fucking face. Learn how to
play the trumpet. A shut the fuck up.
I can't stand it. But at once he's done
and he does his little fucking head bop.
And I never liked that fucking guy.
I used to like him.
And one time I read miles
Davis autobiography and he
trashed cab Calloway saying
that when a is he ratted somebody out for
fucking haven't drugs on him, you know,
which was basically the jazz musician
version of those fucking assholes who
ratted out actors for being potentially
members of the Communist Party in the
50s to Joe McCarthy. So fuck him.
But once he's out of it, all right,
with this stupid conch, when he gets
the fuck out of the goddamn video,
watch these two guys. It's unfucking
believable, man. Just the, the,
the level of talent that these guys have
is insane. All right. And then, you know,
last week I hiked those videos about
the new planet of the apes moving comic
movie coming out.
Um,
people sent in some smart chimp videos.
These things are fucking awesome. Uh,
one is of a chimp. Uh, they,
they stick a peanut in the bottom
of this giant graduated cylinder.
And I gotta be honest with you,
I couldn't figure out how to get
this fucking thing out of there.
And this chimp figures it out.
Um,
I think we're actually going to facilitate
them taking over the planet if we
keep to keep teaching them this shit.
At the very least,
being smarter than half the people in
shop class a. Then there's another video,
another smart chimp trying
to get them to work together.
Human beings are so fucking stupid.
The scientists out there trying to get
chimps, trying to get them to help move,
like move up a heavy piece,
this heavy rock to get them to learn
how to pull all in the same direction,
teach them that fucking skill,
you know,
so right there they can get knee a
bomb shelter back in the day if you,
if you had all my God, they're the
fucking chimpanzees are gonna rip met my,
my God damn nuts off and my face off.
He could go into your bomb shelter
and clothes, that fucking metal.
They're going to teach them how to open
it up. And then there's the last one.
Steve Vai Acoustic.
I know you're here and this is a,
I totally respect Steve Vai.
Um, he's one of those guys who,
he was a hired gun during the
hair metal days and he survived.
He carved out his own niche. He never
stopped creating and he goes around,
he sells out theaters.
He's making his money.
I told you guys that are my favorite
behind the music of all time was vanilla
ice because he still had his money. I have
to seeing all those broke down. I mean,
most of the guys,
a lot of guys still had them money.
Molly Cruz still had their
money. I liked that one. Um,
Aerosmith's was great because
they still had them on.
I just hated seeing the guy I hate.
I hate seeing people fail. I hate it,
you know, unless it's the Canadians,
the Yankees, the jets or the Lakers.
Dude,
if anybody can tell me how the Lakers
aren't going to win the championship this
year with the fucking old
ass Celtics trading away,
Kendrick Perkins and the spurs losing to
the Er, the fucking grizzlies. It's over.
There is no fucking way the Lakers aren't
going to win the championship score.
Detroit Redwings I'm trying to jinx the
Lakers by saying that cause other than
that, I don't think there's
anything stopping them. Um,
so anyways, what the fuck was I talking
about? I totally lost my frame of thought,
my train of thought or my
frame of reference or in my
world, my frame of thought.
I'm a fucking moron. Um, the
fuck was he talking about?
Okay.
Yeah, it's gone. People, it's gone
forever. That's how my brain works out,
right in the end of the
podcast, let's, uh, let's hype
my dates. What do I got here?
Uh, coming up. Oh, by the way, I told
you guys I was doing David Letterman. Um,
that is not going to be happening
because believe it or not,
guess who got called back for another
episode of Glee speak in a dancing.
See what you guys don't realize
is when I sing on the podcast,
I'm just fucking around.
I actually have a wonderful
voice and I am a triple threat.
I can deliver the jokes,
I can sing the songs and I can fucking a,
I can do a little Shim Sham.
I can dance.
Yeah.
Um, yeah. Um,
that bringing me back to gleek and I'm
actually doing the singing and dance
number with a,
that an androgynous kid who hangs out
with that fucking angry blonde chick.
We're going to be singing a,
I want a new drug,
but we're doing the club version. So
it's going to be really, really sexy.
And we wouldn't want to lose a v neck
tee shirts that shows man cleavage.
It's going to be awesome.
So look for that.
So I won't be doing
Letterman because of that.
And also I'm going to be at
the antisocial comedy tour,
February, um, February May
13th and a in Washington,
DC. Go to antisocial comedy.com, uh,
for all your tickets and all the links.
Like I said,
these tickets are selling very fast.
I don't know how long we're going to be
doing this tour or how long where uh,
I dunno. That's hilarious. I
basically said what I wanted to say.
I want to say how long this tour is going
to last or how long we're going to be
doing this tour.
And I got right to the second one on my
brain just shuts off cause it works in a
straight line.
Yeah.
I don't know how long we're going to be
doing this tour and how long this lineup
is going to last.
And uh,
I gotta tell you it's been a long fucking
time since I've been on a show where I
just stand and I watched the entire show.
I'm a comedian.
Nothing makes me fucking laugh and I am
working with three fucking base on this
and uh, it's worth every
God damn sent I guarantee.
So make sure you get your ass down
there. Um, and other than that,
I'm going to be doing Caroline's comedy
club May 19th through the 22nd and uh,
and then the Chicago theater,
another anti social network tour.
We added Seattle last week and
we're also doing Las Vegas.
All those dates are up on
antisocial comedy.com and that's it.
And one last plug I got to do.
Mother's Day coming up, guys. Come on,
do it for your mother. Go to pro
flowers.com. Click on the, uh,
the microphone in the upper right corner.
Uh, when it asks you for the code,
type in Berbee you are
R and a and shop away.
They'll deliver them right to your
house. It's perfect. You know,
don't get yourself into that situation
where you want. That's fucking off sides.
Thank you
Jesus Christ.
Take your fucking whistle out.
So anyways,
go to pro pro pro pro flowers.com.
Click on the microphone in the
upper right hand corner. Type in B,
u r r is the code.
Gets your mother some flowers.
Get your girlfriend's mother some flowers.
Get your grandmother's from
flowers for once. Be a swell guy.
You know it's going to be all set.
Then you write something nice
in the car and you're all set.
You don't even have to
leave your fucking house.
How great is that? You know,
if you, one of these people,
are you scared of the Internet?
Uh, you like me, you know,
if that's what you liked and you can
just call La, there's a one 800 number.
Where the fuck is it?
One 800 pro flowers and mentioned the
Monday morning podcasts and my name bill
burr order the fucking flowers.
And that's it.
That's the art Jesus hour and 11
minutes. I still went over. All right.
But I also did 10 minutes of
commercials. Um, that's it.
That's it for this week.
Um,
thank you to everybody who came
out and saw our film a cheat. Um,
we're going to be a, I think we're going
to be doing a film festival in Chicago.
I will have more information about that
next week or in the or in the upcoming
weeks.
Um,
we shall be in more film festivals and
podcast listeners will get a chance to
check out the film.
We're currently writing a book and when
that comes out in the beginning of next
year, the full short, uh,
of the film cheat will be
available in the back of the book.
And we're going to do a little
tour. Hopefully me, Bobby,
and Joe will be selling the book signing.
I'm taking pictures,
smiling and waving in 2012 trying to
sell as many books as we can before old
Jesus comes back and tells us what a bunch
of cuts we are. All right. That's it.
That's the podcast for this week. A go
fuck yourselves. Don't take any shit off.
Talk to you next week.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] no,
stay.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
[inaudible].